you
you
project thinking rewards doing the
minimum to meet the project's
specifications the project scope and not
screwing up while doing it and it's not
very customer focused right your focus
when you're working on a project is to
succeed by the minimum standards of the
project and most often you're never even
talking to a customer but that's not
even the worst part right that's not
even the biggest issue of why I get
upset when we talk about you know when I
say stop thinking about api's as
projects is that projects a planned work
with an end date and end date like api's
Drive mobile they drive web they drive
IOT all the smart cars all the smart
appliances or at your smart vacuum
cleaner all these things that's not
going away
right that's only getting bigger and
bigger and bigger a huge part of our
lives the main core part of how we do
business so why would that have an end
date right that that doesn't make any
sense at all so when I come and visit
you folks at your various offices and
you tell me that you're thinking about
becoming API centric you're thinking
about becoming a platform doing some
digital transformation you always ask
Brian what's the big mistake like you've
seen people do this all around the world
what's the one big mistake that we're
likely to make and the fact that you're
tuned in to a session like this the fact
that you're asking the question means
you might not make that mistake but the
big mistake I see is passing the potato
you are all wondering right why I'm
showing you a potato in the middle of
the workday it's because when you take
the hot potato and you pass it so when I
say say to somebody let's talk about
api's
oh let me have you talk to my director
of operations wait a minute I definitely
should talk to your director of
operations at some point just like I
should talk to your architects
developers security but we're talking
about market share here we're talking
about revenue we're talking about your
brand right we're talking about your
partner ecosystem your developer
ecosystem these are serious high-level
topics
these aren't operational
concerns and and why does this happen
it's because API sound geeky right I
wish there were I wish there was a way
that we could have these conversations
without even using the word API because
it does it sounds super technical super
geeky and there's obviously a deep
technical component to it but api's are
so much more than that
now okay Brian if they're not a project
if you're you're telling us stop
thinking of api's as a project and then
what are they how should we think about
api's well let's think about that for a
second right api's might be a program
right we all know a program is a cluster
of projects so this is better if I come
to visit your office and you say hey
Brian I want to talk to you about our
API program I'll be a little happier
right because that shows that you're
thinking about it in broader terms that
you recognize that this is technology
that you can leverage across multiple
lines of business across multiple
projects that's great
another possibility is a platform right
now one one slide that I often like to
show is talking about the most valuable
companies in the world today versus say
25 years ago 15 years ago right and if
we look at the most valuable companies
in the world from 15 years ago 25 years
ago it's all of usual suspects right
it's all the people you would expect
your giant petroleum companies General
Motors right the big industrial
companies and if you look at the most
valuable companies in the world from
last year right it's Apple and Google
alphabet and it's Microsoft and Facebook
and Amazon and always people say oh
Brian I get it is Silicon Valley
companies wrong I mean yeah they all are
Silicon Valley companies but there are a
lot of Silicon Valley companies that
aren't on that list right okay Brian I
get it they're all software companies
wrong I mean yes they are all software
companies but there's a lot of software
companies that aren't on that list if
you look at the most valuable companies
in the world the thing that you'll
immediately notice that they all have in
common is that they're all platforms
that means they allow other people
outside of traditional organizational
boundaries to participate in their
success
right now this is very very powerful
because this is no longer a hypothesis
or a guess this is now empirical
evidence of how you succeed in the 21st
century which is very different from how
you succeeded in the 20th century right
we we all learned how to do business by
raising barriers to entry right instead
of lowering barriers to cooperation
which is how you win a 21st century that
is a pretty big shift and again while
some of this can seem semantic think
about the thousand decisions that your
company is going to make this month if
you're making them on the twentieth
century model of raising barrier to
entry versus the 21st century model of
becoming a platform lowering barriers to
cut it to a cooperation that's going to
result in a very different outcome for
the success of your company possibly the
survival of your company now api's might
be a program there might be a platform
they'd be quite pleased if I came anyone
to talk to me about your your platform
project turning your business into a
platform because honestly if you're not
creating a digital ecosystem or
participating in an ecosystem you
probably only have a couple of years to
continue doing business in your current
form now that can mean a lot of
different things and I don't mean to
sound too gloomy but this is the reality
of today's market now the third
possibility of what an API is if it's
not a project is a way of life right
api's might just be the kind of thing
that become ubiquitous in our business
in technology now why would I say that
obviously I love api's right I am the
the sticker on my laptops and the
sticker on my briefcase and I dream
about this stuff when I'm at home but
api's power customer experience and the
second big mistake I see most companies
making today most of these big
traditional powerhouse companies when I
come to visit your offices is it it's so
inwardly focused and so focused on your
existing data centers your existing
technologies and the battle right now is
on the front end the battle is about the
experiences now though people on the
front end may be your employees it
doesn't have to be customers it's often
customers it can be point-of-sale people
at stores right it can be your partners
in your supply chain your employees any
one of these people
they are demanding a better customer
experience because we're all doing
business in 2018 whether we want to or
not we can't say we're not ready and
doing business in 2018 means that
everybody expects you to get to market
faster it means that they expect
self-service they expect you to be on
the platforms on which they're happiest
and most productive we've all been
trained to expect these things and
there's really no way out of it you know
I see so many companies still focusing
on eking an extra 5% of performance out
of the back end and not focused on
delighting their users with great
customer experiences like api's would
help them to do api's also enable the
the ecosystems and platforms I just
talked about how essentially empirically
the way to win in the 21st century is to
become a platform or to participate on a
platform to become an ecosystem or to
participate in an ecosystem there really
is no other answer and it just so
happens that AP is are a fantastic way
to allow your company to do these things
now API is drive revenue and growth
right think about it if you could
suddenly get your apps onto a bunch of
new devices just statistically speaking
you have a bigger addressable market if
you can make changes faster if you can
say yes to more partnerships right
that'll kind of Hollywood model where
they make 10 movies and eight of them
lose money and the ninth one breaks even
and the 10th went to Blockbuster and
pays for the next 10 films the problem
is they don't know which one that is so
they you know they have to make the next
10 films partnerships and Technology
experiments in the company can feel that
way right that most of them lose money
most of them aren't worth the time and
effort what if there was a self-service
platform what if there was a technology
and a methodology that would help us to
just say yes to every partner who comes
and says we'd like to do some some
business together and see which one is
the blockbuster if you say yes to every
10 statistically over time you're going
to discover new revenue streams you're
going to discover that your business has
a bunch of exciting new partnerships and
products that really would never have
come organically from inside the
organization now whenever we have new
folks starting
and Apogee and especially like a new new
PR firm or somebody wants to understand
Brian what's the reason why so many of
our customers buy the apogee product and
I said that you know there's a lot
there's security and scale and ease of
use and experience there's I mean
there's a lot of good reasons but I
think fundamentally it comes down to
speed right every CIO I talked to every
CTO I talked around the world without
fail says the business is crazy
they're asking me to move faster than
we've ever moved before to release onto
multiple platforms simultaneously
we're just frankly not set up for that
right and every time I talk to the CMO
they say my IT is broken they're too
slow they're too expensive and they keep
saying no to everything so what if there
were a technology and a methodology like
api's that would allow you to decouple
those two worlds that's what api's do
fundamentally is to help you move faster
to allow each side to move at its own
speed you've heard to speed IT and and
that's a somewhat judgment Laden term
but you get the idea that each each end
the front end and the back end can move
at their own pace api's are a perfect
tool for enabling that so ok that's
starting not to sound so geeky we've
talked about why this often that hot
potato gets passed because this sounds
like a really geeky topic but if we're
talking about customer experience right
our customer satisfaction they're not
eroding our market share holding off
some of our disruptors or traditional
competitors if we're talking about
participating in an ecosystem becoming
our business itself becoming a platform
and becoming one of those winners in the
21st century like we looked at before if
we're talking about something that may
contribute to revenue and growth and
something that's going to help us move
faster so that our customers are happier
our employees are happier and as IT the
business gets off our backs and says
okay you guys are delivering exactly
what we need you to deliver that doesn't
sound so geeky that sounds really
important and hopefully you'll see that
those are the kind of conversations we
should be having when we come and visit
now philosophy logic a bit of a hobby of
mine so I like the idea of a category
steak and for those who don't know a
category mistake was an idea created by
the the 20th century philosopher at
Gilbert Ryle he was at Cambridge or
Oxford I can never keep those two
straight let's say was Cambridge and he
took his friend to visit the University
and showed them the dining hall and the
dormitories and the lecture halls and
all that and the friend said this is all
great where's Cambridge so the friend
had made a category mistake they thought
Cambridge was a type of building and
Cambridge is a type of University and I
see these it's a very powerful tool to
understand where companies are making
mistakes so companies are making a
category mistake by thinking that some
business level catalysts something that
affects customer satisfaction that
affects revenue that affects
partnerships that expect that affects
time to market is somehow an operational
issue right in my mind this is so
mind-blowing to me that I often think of
it it's like saying that well our
company's revenue is really mostly a
pencil sharpening issue right I mean
it's it's the operational aspect there
of sharpening that pencil of course not
sharpening that pencil has nothing to do
with your company's revenue that is that
it's a complete category mistake but how
does this happen so when I was a
technology executive in New York my
teams would often come me they'd come
into my office in the morning and say
Brian that guy's being a jerk and I'd
say I don't think so
I don't believe it I mean it was Wall
Street it's possible but I don't believe
anybody woke up this morning looked in
the mirror and said I'm gonna be a jerk
today right so we need to find some
other explanation for what's going on
right this person thinks that their
mandate is such-and-such and they think
they're executing against that mandate
so maybe they don't understand the scope
of their job right maybe they don't
understand the priorities of the
organization there's some other
motivation I think than just being a
jerk now we know that some of the
miskeen miscommunication happens because
api's sound geeky but every organization
has blind spots and just like I was
talking about that the the folks coming
into my office in New York I noticed
there's a lot of miscommunication right
on the one side we have business which
is obviously trying to do the right
thing keep everybody gainfully employed
delight the customer
right and on the other side you've got
technology which is trying to do what
it's supposed to do which is prevent
breaches right make sure that disaster
recovery and business continuity are
covered audits all these all these great
things right you have two smart groups
of people who are both competent trying
to do the right thing and yet we end up
in the situation we're in today which is
it takes us too long to get new things
to market our customers aren't happy
we're not on all the devices the apps
aren't as good as some of the startup
you know flashy apps how can we not get
this solved right and that's because
there's this chasm where there's a
language and a process barrier between
these two worlds and everybody thinks
they're saying the same thing and yet
it's not it's not resulting in the
positive so I was told a few years ago a
story of the CEO of one of the major
world airlines who was flying for
whatever reason on a competitor's flight
they didn't have a route that flew that
way and he noticed this was several
years ago he noticed that they had media
controls in the armrest
and he said this is fantastic we have to
do this for our customers and he got
Iggy landed and he called up his
lieutenants and he said you know we have
to we have to make these things for our
customers and so there's trickled
through the organization let's put media
controls on the armrest to delight our
customers and what do you suppose
happened each group started saying well
we can use the existing armrest we'll
just drill a hole underneath and then
kind of superglue a little panel in
there and you guys all remember this
from a few years ago we could fall
asleep on an airplane it's like a
gravity well your arm would get sucked
in it would start to fall asleep and
tingle in really bad ways your elbow
would always hit the volume button
things like that it was miserable and if
you think about a plane with 300 people
on it you're talking months of person
hours of misery being added to every
flight and the goal was you recall
delight our customers right but it got
mistranslated as it passed through the
organization and some people heard that
is save money some people thought that
meant let's be as clever as we can
reusing existing parts it got all good
people all trying to do something that
they thought was the right thing to do
and yet it resulted in misery
fortunately we've gone to the
touchscreen area and we're not not
really doing that anymore as a very
frequent flyer
this is great for me but this to me
starts to explain how we have two
different worlds and how we can end up
in this crazy situation now I know it
can sound like I'm saying a lot of doom
and gloom right but let's talk about
some good news there is a way to solve
this I know there's a lot to look at
when we're looking at all the other
things other than simply deploying a
technology configuring a technology when
we're talking about governance and
funding and all these various bits that
go around it they just kind of have to
be done and are very important to
getting things done but they're not the
the cool technology bits if you look at
the problem domain right so this is a
third big mistake that I see companies
making as they try to solve one sixth of
the problem and I don't get that at all
right you guys have a bunch of stuff
that you've built and bought over the
years you have an end user often a
customer maybe an employee on the other
side if you can't get from point A to
point B you have not solved the problem
and so my mind is blown all the time
when people come and talk to me well we
you know we we found a vendor that'll
sell us a developer website great you
need a developer website it's necessary
it's not sufficient right I mean what
happens when they they start building
apps right what happens when traffic
starts flowing through don't you need
scale and security and monetization all
these other things or you know my ESB
vendor or somebody on the backend has a
lot of me to do some exposure great
exposures not the problem and a runtime
is critical it's necessary but it's not
sufficient right what about all the
developer tools what about analytics
what about all the other pieces you got
to get from point A to point B that's
the problem domain and of course the
players who's involved in this now
the problem domain can be easily
visualized as I said from all the stuff
you've built and bought all the way out
to the end user says customer here but
just any end user and I think you'd
agree with me that if you don't get from
point A to point B you simply haven't
solved the problem and that's why it's
so confusing to me when people talk to
me about solving 1/6 of the problem it
just it makes no sense now we know the
players that are involved in this too
right so I said if you can identify the
entire problem domain and identify who
the players are it starts to make more
sense because some people think oh no
they're cookie liqueurs you know that
idea like when you were 10 and you
didn't want your siblings to get one of
the cookies so you lick all the cookies
and nobody else can eat one
this happens in organizations all the
time too right I'm gonna I'm gonna lick
this cookie and this is my cookie and no
one else gets to play so it's good to
get on the on the whiteboard on the on
the screen whatever who is involved here
who are the other players another way to
look at it a more abstract way is to say
okay we've got we've got lines of
business and generally in a federated
technology organization they've got line
of business TAC but we've also got the
brand and we've got Enterprise
technology and there's usually a kind of
an unhealthy tension between these two
things
when fundamentally they all want the
same thing and I've been very pleased to
see how much api's tend to reduce this
tension between these two groups
so since api's are just going to be part
of how we do business and live our lives
from now on like water to fish it's just
going to be ubiquitous and how we live
think about how to streamline governance
so I know some people are very extreme
in their view that api's make governance
go away I don't believe that coming from
big fortune 500 companies myself I think
that it does streamline governance I
think a restful api just by necessity
needs less governance than an old
fashioned soap contract would for
example to think about it's the classic
debate of who funds these things right
that the groups are going to benefit
most from their consumption or the the
back end teams themselves I mean think
about realistically how we can fund this
better because I talked to so many
organizations when we come in and help
them and and it turns out that they they
feel like they cannot do business as a
brand or across whatever organizational
trust boundary whether that's a
department division line of business
whatever but api's give you this
abstraction layer does they I don't
really care how they implemented this I
don't really care how what they what a
customer looks like in their database I
don't even truly need a single source of
truth we've now got an interface that
all of our developers know how to use
that all of our architects know how to
use and and now we can go forward and do
clever things like the commercial models
to say how could we charge differently
now could we now have subscription
offerings could we do revenue sharing we
do advertising based off there's a lot
of different ways to make money that
might not have been available to you
before you became API centric so API is
in my experience tend to be
a forcing function for an organization
and the secret right that's why it's not
in tiny print it's in big print is that
the challenge won't be technology this
this technology just the apogee platform
itself for example as one example
it just has billions and billions of
calls going through it
that's fourth-generation technology it's
the technology is well and truly solved
it's the other bits of the organization
can we switch from being a 20th century
company to a 21st century mindset right
can we start thinking in terms of not
being not being reduced to blindly
following our governance and our
existing processes but think about
customer delight think about that
problem domain and how we can work
together to solve that so how do we
start doing that Brian that all sounds
great that's like a performance report
where your boss says do better
that's not very actionable you can't do
much with it so I would say hey you can
start with a single API where you got to
start somewhere
try to make it a key API when I work
with retail companies and say you know
we'll start with a store locator I think
you know no one's gonna get fired if the
store locator fails that's not critical
path you need to do something that's
gonna be critical path recognize that an
operational aspect will exist
whoa-oh-oh-oh Brian you've been telling
us the whole time this isn't an
operational issue that's a category
mistake right it is a category mistake
but that doesn't mean there's not an
operational aspect to it and it would be
just as foolish to ignore the security
the the day-to-day operations and try
some new things people ask me all over
the world
what makes Silicon Valley so different
why isn't you've worked in New York
you've worked in Europe you know what
what makes things so different here and
I think one of the big key factors it's
just my opinion is that in Silicon
Valley it's ok to fail in fact failing
fast is a good idea and gives you data
that you wouldn't get any other way it
gives you a tremendous amount of data
now when I was in New York I often felt
like if I had a big Marquis project that
failed
it might torpedo my career at that
company right that might be enough to
stop my forward advancement at that
company and that's simply not the case
out here and I encourage people to try
to adopt that mindset that nobody gets
an API right on the first try nobody
usually gonna rev it at least three
times the first year so be ok with that
API is
there there a facade so they're not
heavy and expensive like a back-end
system and people seem to have trouble
making this mind shift now it's okay to
experiment and prototype with api's so
one of the things we do to understand
this market better and to help our
customers understand themselves better
as we have this tool called compass you
can find it at compass Apogee comm and
it's a series of questions that help
help basically to assess the digital
maturity of an organization now most of
the folks that are be listening to this
you are the ones who are to get it
you're the ones who already know but you
probably have a lot of colleagues around
your organization who don't get it
who wonder why it's not still okay you
know we did business like this in 20th
century and it made us very successful
and you know why would we change that or
you know what we don't need help we are
already digital we're already
transforming we're already doing these
things and so what we found is it's
actually likely that some people in your
organization are saying the right words
that somebody's producing some kind of
vision plan some kind of road map that
has some of the right things on it and
that's great news because that wasn't
the case a couple of years ago but we're
really finding is where companies are
stumbling around execution and while
it's great to say the right words it's
got to have output or it means nothing
and so we're finding that that companies
just don't have the right executive
support again that API sounded very
geeky and and and they they're not
looking at it across the organization
and at the brand level enough and
they're not thinking about who's gonna
make it who's gonna support it and who's
gonna consume it and therefore that that
nifty Vision Plan and all those
buzzwords that are being put on the
whiteboards really amount to nothing
it's even worse than nothing because
it's fooling the organization into
thinking that they're transforming now
another question I get all the time is
you know Brian we've invested in ESB
technologies so what technologies so do
we need this stuff I think you know I
think we're okay and you know of course
you have I mean that's what everybody
did for the last 10 to 15 years but
those are integration technologies right
and then the fact that your integration
technology will allow you to do some
exposure actually means nothing my
exposure is not the problem exposure is
easy taking a complicated thing
moving it one layer forward in the
architecture solves no nothing right if
it's not being consumed now it's not
going to be consumed then right this is
all about consumption this is a new
layer in the architecture it generally
sits in front of the integration tier
the the so and ESB kind of tier this is
the exposure and consumption layer with
a heavy focus on consumption because
when you have transactions flowing
through the system that's where your
revenue comes from that's where
delighted customers weren't come from
when you have an API that can be easily
consumed right treated as a product not
a project and think about all the design
implement implications of a product
versus a project we should take photos
of doors every time we visited a company
around the world not the Jim Morrison
group the actual doors on the front of a
building and what we noticed is a lot of
times there would be like a pull bar and
a little sign that said push now if you
know how our brains work right we have
the lizard brain that evolved over
millions and millions of years and we
have the frontal cortex which does
verbal and is very very new and you know
which one wins when you have bad design
and a little bit of documentation the
lizard brain every time right every
single time and so you can't paper over
bad design with documentation right this
is that's what it means to be a product
is to think about the affordance think
about just by looking at this API
I understand how they want me to use it
now another mistake that I see companies
making is they don't respect the
developers enough as much as I've talked
about this as being a business level
high level you know technology
leadership kind of issue developers are
the kingmakers api's are essentially
invisible right and if you don't have
your people your contractors your
digital agencies your third parties
building fantastic apps off of these
api's what's the point there they're
essentially invisible and then another
thing that I think is difficult for
traditional companies and traditional
organizations to get their heads around
is that Minimum Viable is still viable
right so it's this idea well if we don't
have an 18-month project if we don't
have these golden magical requirements
that are somehow perfect and we'll never
change and I believe don't exist like
how are we ever going to produce
anything but
idea is if we can get something into the
hands of our users especially if it's an
internal project so it's it's for some
line of business some Department the
faster we get things into their hands
the faster we get feedback about how
this is used in the real world and they
say that no no combat plan survives
contact with the enemy and I found the
same thing about api's is that no API no
matter how good your practitioners are
no matter how much you know about API is
no API survives first contact with the
developers you need to see how the API
behaves in the wild is consumed in the
wild to really understand that API and
as I mentioned earlier if it came down
to one thing you know what if I'm trying
to convince my colleagues about why we
need to be API first why we need to be
API centric it's about speed it simply
allows our different departments and
groups to move faster it allows us to
get ideas into production faster it
allows us to onboard developers faster
to on four onboard partners faster to on
onboard digital agencies faster it
allows us to look more modern and more
disruptive even if we're consider
ourselves to be a big traditional
bureaucratic organization and then user
experience like I said it's just it's
not the muscle memory of most
traditional companies to think in terms
of user experience we've tended to have
kind of a captive audience it's okay if
we're a generation or two behind on the
graphics or the devices but it's really
really important to focus on the user
experience people are voting with their
dollars voting with the apps right the
revolution wasn't the apps the the
iPhone the revolution was the App Store
a couple months later that's how we live
our lives that's where the revolution is
hopefully these have been I know this is
kind of a weird section in that it
wasn't about installation what's my
configuration it wasn't about the code
it wasn't about a live demo of the
product it was around all those other
bits that go around it but unfortunately
our just is necessary to be successful
and I want you all to have very
successful API projects and and so I can
tell great stories as I fly around the
world about what you guys have done if
you want to dig deeper we do have a few
resources we have a microsite dedicated
to this topic and there's a brand new
hot off the presses ebook about how to
stop thinking about api's as projects
and start thinking them
as products now with that said I'm going
to pause here for a moment and I'll
allow you guys time to put any questions
into the system you'd like to put in and
I'll be back in just a second to answer
some of those questions thank you
you
okay everyone thanks for staying with us
we did get a couple of questions I'd
like to quickly address those one
question was can we configure Google
cloud products you know some of the
existing Google cloud products and api's
such as bigquery or others using Apogee
so the answer is yes of course we have a
lot of customers who front many other
backend API so various Maps various if
you think about some of the commerce
applications some of the transaction and
settlement software a lot of those
third-party api's get fronted in Apogee
so yes of course it's always able to do
you're always able to do any API
including the Google Cloud API is now
the subtext of this might be since
Apogee as part of Google cloud is there
some kind of deeper integration and the
answer is not yet but again Google API
is are so well designed that it is very
easy to plug in plug Appaji in front of
them there it really doesn't take a lot
of work at all there's a few other
questions where you know where does
Apogee fit into the architecture that we
already have you know hopefully I
convinced you a little bit this is very
different than an integration technology
you probably have ESB some soma
technologies and this would generally
sit in front front of that and so Apogee
is a great bridge from legacy
technologies to the cloud technologies
from legacy technologies to modern apps
Android and iPhone apps and things like
that and you know it would generally sit
behind the the firewall and the load
balancers as one of the edge
technologies that's why we called it
Apogee edge as it's meant to sit in
front of all those back-end technologies
and if you hit our website or you ping
us afterwards there's you know we'd be
happy to do an architectural deep dive
and you can see some various diagrams
and white papers where we go into this
you know how do we start focusing on
consumption instead of exposure
this is dangerous because a lot of
legacy vendors are telling you well
we've we've added some bells and
whistles that allow you to to exposure
and and make it sound like that's that's
the answer I would think you know I was
working a large telecommunications
company one day doing a seminar and API
design best practice and they kept
stumbling they were trying to design
their their texting API
right there SMS API and they kept having
like a hundred data fields in there and
I kept saying to myself I don't I'm not
an expert in this field but it seems
like you've got a sender a timestamp
content and an array of receivers so
like four fields something like that I
mean whatever it is it's closer to four
than it is a hundred and I said to them
why do you think it's a hundred like why
I mean you're the experts but why is
this they said well you know we just
updated this system to seven point two
point eight but nobody cares right no
but nobody should ever care or know
about that information right with API is
you got to think outside not not inside
somebody outside of our organization
outside of our department whatever what
are they coming to us for like why do
they come here why do they come to us
and make that as easy to consume as
possible make your your best goods on
offer as a super consumable API that's
the way to start thinking about
consumption is the other parts of the
business that come to us why do they
come to us what's what's our core
offering for them our customers what's
the main reason they come to us how can
I make that as easy to consume as
possible instead of what are the
advantages or limitations of my back-end
systems or what kind of version or
vendor I've got on my back-end stuff and
one question I get all the time is Brian
you keep telling us not to think of the
api's as a project right think of as a
product but we're starting with a
project are you know are we wrong it's
just the wrong thing to do and of course
not you've you often in a big
organization will have a project that's
funded that's staffed if it has a
charter that's on your portfolio that's
great that's a perfect way it's a
perfect opportunity to introduce these
technologies and introduce this
methodology as long as you're aware that
this goes well beyond that project right
api's should be the center of every
project you do your API platform should
span lines of business and be across the
entire brand as long as you go into that
single project with that mindset you
won't make those you know I'm a lifelong
Software Architect those thousand
decisions that you make none of which by
themselves are critical but if you make
them all in the wrong direction you're
going to end up at a very different
outcome and so if you think of this is
not just for this project but this is
the future of the company
then the project is a great way to get
started right and and to me after these
kinds of sessions some people say well
Brian I know your your you love
linguistics you love language things
like that is this just fundamentally a
semantic issue and I truly don't believe
that you know any of you who have built
software which I assume as most of you
know that it's not just you know what
color the button is and where it goes on
the screen there are thousand questions
and design decisions that we have to do
along the creation of a product and if
we make all those decisions in a way
that thinks of this in a very inside
first traditional 20th century kind of
mindset the result is going to be
unfortunate what we see all over the app
stores right now which is traditional
companies just kind of looking silly
with their apps how far behind they are
graphically and usability and we're all
friends right we all have have companies
that we're customers of and we're
frustrated with their apps and why can't
this be more like you know some Silicon
Valley startups fantastic glamorous app
and I think that's the harm I think the
harm is thinking that what got you there
in the 20th century is what's going to
win in the 21st century when it
empirically we know that that's not true
right and so not focusing on the
experience the customer experience not
focusing on speed right not focusing on
working across organizational trust
boundaries I don't think that's
semantics at all and I think that's that
fundamentally like statistically will
lead you to situations that are
conducive to failing in the 21st century
just as if you are API centric and
you're thinking of things in terms of
products and consumed ability and
customer experience it doesn't guarantee
success but it creates conditions that
are conducive to success in the current
digital app based 21st century
marketplace that we all have to compete
in whether we like it or not in every
region of the globe and every vertical
we're all doing business in 2018 and
this is simply what our employees our
developers our partners and our
customers have come to expect from us so
I think that's all the questions that we
had and I know sometimes it's hard when
you're on the spot here to think of a
question right now if you think of one
when you're taking a shower tomorrow
morning and
you know I wish I'd asked Brian this
question feel free to ping us anytime
reach out to us we'd be happy to talk we
love talking about this stuff and we get
very fired up talking about this stuff
and otherwise we hope that you'll tune
in to our next next week next Tuesday
for the next cloud on-air webinar my
name is Brian Pagano come to you from
Google cloud thank you so much for your
time today